as you can see we took our show on the
road today or at least
to the road outside here from our studio
on 57th street
in new york and it's time for a special
outdoor edition of
cookbook club
the notion that great barbecue only
comes from the south was debunked
by this former bodyguard turned pit
master from brooklyn
so here to show us how to switch up our
thanksgiving spread
from the kitchen to the smoker the owner
of hometown
barbecue please welcome billy durney
hi billy thanks for having me today oh
i'm so glad that we could do this
together
i'm so excited and i'm so excited to get
you uh
amongst our smokey little fire here it's
pretty uh
pretty perfect for the holiday so the
most successful turkey i ever made for
thanksgiving
was brined yes and that is
i think a crucial step in a very
flavorful
juicy amazing turkey and i'm really
excited
to demo a brine because sometimes when
it's just
words on a page or in a book i am a very
visual person so that's why i even
wanted to pour the water because
sometimes i'm like
how much water are you talking a bucket
a cup
what right so for here we're going to
use a half a gallon or gallons of water
water
for one breast so we could just throw
that in we do that now yeah we could
just
throw that in right over so half of this
oh we can put the whole gallon
all right let's do it yeah
beautiful so it's fully fully submerged
the turkey's fully submerged is
basically what we're going i'm a fully
submerged turkey
all right so now most brines start
really simply with salt and sugar so
we have sugar and salt how much would
you i would say a cup
so i'd say yeah that'll
another little snudge i don't know if
smudge is a word but
i i say it's a word all right so like a
cup
a generous cup generous cup and then
equal parts i like to put equal parts
sugar and salt
and then we like um whole peppercorns in
ours
i think the brine i did um all of them
no no that's good it's good
the one i did had like an anna yeah anis
is good so people
a lot of people use juniper berry and
like other floral things
um but i like to keep it more savory and
herby yeah
and i love garlic tons of garlic okay
i would throw
and then we would throw the herbs in
there i throw them in hole
now you can bruise them so you can kind
of break them if you want
but we like using the whole thing
um not taking anything off the stems and
that's it we just
drew i love you you're getting in there
not messing around
i want to love the bird you are the bird
is being
the bird is being tenderized by drew
barrymore it's a baby
this will just sit essentially cold four
hours
for about 20 12 even 12 hours would be
enough but 12 to 24 hours would be
plenty enough for this one breath
and don't exceed 24 hours i wouldn't
because then it gets over salted
and then it like almost keeps all the
water in when you're cooking exactly
it's the reverse so instead of when we
cut the birds that are coming off the
smoker today
it'll be a little more chewy and and it
won't have the same tenderness and
moistness it's just like me
after a lot of takeout next day
shriveling off it's like you could
squeeze me and it would still just keep
coming out
i love that so that's how the turkey
looks going into the brine
and now we can open the smoker and then
we'll see what they look like cooked
right
and my friend calls me um epcot because
she says i eat like i'm traveling the
world
world i like that can i call you epcot
oh thank you that's why i told you
so we're gonna lift this guy up
and we're gonna pull this pull this bad
boy out
really hot and
i'm gonna put one of these turkeys on
your board
wow for you
and then here i'm gonna move my brine
i'm gonna put one of these turkeys on
here for me
and now we're gonna talk about how do we
cut this bad boy
so we're gonna go normally we'd start
but
i want you to see see the opening so
we'll go a little further in
okay and i kind of like to use my hand
as a guide and then
kind of cut it cut it through there so
wow so
you could see all the pink around yeah
the turkey
so that's an indication that it was
smoked on wood
all right so go ahead and cut you can
cut right into it
yeah it's not going to be too hot for
you there you go
beautiful oh my gosh so you see it's
super super tender
and then again wow you have this smoke
ring we're talking about
and then you can if i just did a little
squeeze you can see all this
beautiful moisture wow so it's nice and
tender and
and moist wow and then it depends like
do you like it thicker
do you like it thinner what kind of
slices do you like you know for
like a thanksgiving turkey i go a little
thicker okay
so like on a sandwich i like a thinner
but if you're gonna have like
thanksgiving turkey
a little thicker good i love it it
smells like nothing i've ever smelled
it's so beautiful
i i don't know if this is possible but
like i can smell the juice
perfect so i'm gonna taste the piece
cheers
cheers bud
oh my gosh so super tender
moist not over salty because we didn't
leave it in the brine for too long
the texture is very like it's not
dry no no that's why it's so
it's really wet yeah really wet and
moist
i'm happy with it that's incredible
thank you bud
i've never tasted anything like that i
appreciate that i feel bad eating in
front of everybody this is a whole i
know i want to feed everybody
i'm still like you said that you you're
so nurturing i just want to stop feeding
the crew but
i know i do too i also have to like try
this cornbread
i'm gonna wait wait wait i have to help
you with the cornbread though we're
gonna put honey butter on it
so cornbread honey honey
honey butter and then just a drop of
salt
taste that one which one this yeah this
guy
i'm gonna keep cutting just in case
anybody gets tempted here
so billy today for cookbook club i
wanted to present you
with the melon by amy goldman amazing
what i love about bringing you this book
today is i think
that sometimes you want a little
sweetness or you want a little freshness
and i love the way that melon pairs with
meat
isn't this beautiful so this is from my
personal collection
and i just thought ugh what a great
pairing barbecue and melon so
thank you my darling i actually brought
you a book as well
two of my great friends from the
beautiful country of canada
uh montreal and they own the famous joe
beef
restaurant there this book is called
surviving the apocalypse
well did it come out this year and i
thought no it did not
and uh essentially what this this book
is is all about is
how to be really amazingly um
indulgent in in if there was an
apocalypse
what you would make so for instance deer
belly they have crispy frog legs
i hope as 2020 gets past us
you can if you ever have to survive the
apocalypse thank you very much
if you survive 2020 then thank you so
much
which we will we absolutely will so
thank you thank you so much and billy
derney you are
amazing this was such a special
experience definitely not something
any of us are going to ever forget and
um thank you for joining us
right here on 57th street we'll be right
back
thanks thank you so much
[Music]
you